IBM was thinking of launching the 360
series computers that will be byte
addressable in the early sixties there
was a well-known committee that decided
the character codes we used today the
ASCII committing American Standard Code
for information interchange early
sixties IBM approved variet they even
had delegates on the board so then the
embarrassing questions start coming in
okay so there's these 8-bit characters
where are they going to come from
they're gonna be asking aren't they an
IBM coughed and blushed and spluttered
and said we'll make a statement into
course and a lot of a saw was going to
come up here they'd had half a century
of evolving their own codes which were
based on BCD binary coded decimal
more about that possibly later and they
just kind of evolved the salespeople
gonna burn ours is a little boss this
360 series right if you're saying it
can't use our existing codings on our
card punch which we've been using for
years got BCD I've become AB stick as
extended binary coded decimal
interchange code and that was the IBM
way along with six versions of that
faced historical reasons even now I
don't know if you can get out of IBM
that document that shamefacedly owns up
to six different versions of obviously
look it up on Wikipedia it's hilarious
it really is so basically the solar cell
look if we can still use our peripherals
with this new machinery we can ship
quickly if we start messing about saying
we will be totally ASCII tested and
compliant before we ship we're going to
lose a huge segment potentially of our
market to our competitors so why not
just say you know where you are with IBM
you're not really interested in these
technical details we'll hold your hand
but
under the hood we will carry on using em
stick as our characters and I've no
doubt the comments will be full of
typical I behaved attitudes all about
this but you could see that commercially
for them it made sense oh by the way
Sean have you noticed it has a
unforeseen side effect this it locks
people into using IBM machinery forever
more because they'll be utterly
non-standard everybody else will be
using ASCII is this a bug or is it a
feature you know and I do believe and I
I think while we discussed it before I
do believe that even now
IBM replacement mainframes will be using
app stick inside but did they eventually
get the message and come properly into
the modern world yes they did but it
took a time because as far as I know
some of the earliest machines to
actually use ASCII that where I BM was
when IBM discovery UNIX and decided all
there's all these servers UNIX other
people doing it let's do it the IBM were
a great expense but for our customers
who don't know spending money where's
will so here's the IBM way to do Unix
well they're a IX I think it's called
servers do of course use ASCII life will
be intolerable for them if it didn't so
in a way the absurdity of it could be
confined to the mainframes and kept
behind the IBM wall as it were but just
occasionally problems from apps tick
lept out into the outside world
sometimes as a result of IBM trying to
be helpful would you like to have your
ascii-based PDF accidentally or
deliberately stored and forwarded by an
M stick machine that probably thought it
was part of its duty to translate all
this rogue ASCII into web stick for
internal use and then translate it back
into ASCII again on the way out I
remember Jim King of Adobe telling me it
was his biggest nightmare for ages was
this you know IBM trying to be helpful
yeah store-and-forward ab stick based
machines he said you know I tried to
discover what the common characters were
between ascii and ab stick how much
commonality is there could be a lot that
must be 100 all characters which are in
different mapped positions but
nevertheless they correspond one-to-one
well first problem is for C programmers
there's no curly braces in Epps tick I
don't know how they got around that I'm
guessing some something like use
backslash open paren or something for
curly brace I don't know and anyway Jim
says he said we finally decided to Dobby
there were eight to safe characters that
were into mapable between the two we
were wrong it depends which of the six
version is a purpose that you were using
I think in the end they decided they
were only 64 absolutely safe characters
that could be interconverted between the
two so I think the moral of all this is
that of course increasingly ab stick is
now utterly confined to the I guess
replacement hardware why bother to
reprogram edge it was written in COBOL
in 1965 it's still working we just want
faster hardware to run it on good old
IBM supply what the customers want just
sign here I mean I speak as one who's
seen a meg in a box delivered by IBM
you know three sixty seventy I think it
was and a lot of very words of people
were doing very good data processing
using COBOL and all this kind of stuff
and the thing was so unbelievably slow
and to IBM salesman came buttoned up
holding well we here in England only the
Chancellor holds up a red box with a
budget statement these guys were holding
this box I just happened to be there and
I think think manager computer center
managers name was dawn the luckless and
Don was faced with these guys holding
this black box and I said Don we here
via back channels from your users they
are not happy with the performance of
your machine on the they called an IAS
their database system I forget now
anyway they're not happy Don we have the
solution for what says the luckless
donna learned raining unless it's done
it's a Megan
box and they took out two things that
look more like television cabling with
your plums on you plug them into the Meg
in the box and say open up the CPU based
on some watching all this happening they
put these things are there okay regen I
think that's the IBM where did you regen
the system tell it it it's called a
megabyte more memory so the regen was
done honestly the thing went off like a
Lamborghini compared to what he was
doing before
and the nice thing almost littering the
queue of users outside the door because
of course then the IBM salesmen depart
hey just leave it there
can't you let your users again yeah and
the users are outside Don's door in a
matter of nanoseconds or what if I said
gone that memory stays that memory goes
you die this machine's wonderful this is
the way it should have been and of
course the bill was presented for the
Meg in the box but of course could now
be done as a properly supplied unit but
just for now I think it was something
like $10,000 $10,000 for a Megaman for
this IBM memory Shawn it was so fast the
users were happy I actually saw it in
operation that's the way it worked you
know you've got a lot of money you know
it makes sense don't take chances
they won't sack you dong for spending
and thousand dollars on amazed I was
with IBM there we are
so was that all there was to it no on
the sidelines and treated quite honestly
and shamefacedly I say this in many ways
with a bit of division was commercial
computing and the company as I'm sure
you all know that was instrumental in
leading the way with that was IBM